tout ce qu'on dit là et périphériques
mois pour moi la seule parole qui compte
est la seule parole qui est audible
c'est la parole de la famille bien sûr
la parole des parents si les parents
voulaient ce biopic si les parents
voulaient que ce soit sur tf1 dans ces
conditions là dans ce format là bas
c'est les parents qui ont le dernier mot
et ben on peut demander à pierre
lemarchal au téléphone le papa de
grégory jour et remercie pierre d'être
avec nous pierre merci d'être là pierre
merci d'être avec nous au téléphone je
suis très heureux de voir suis très
heureux de vous avoir au téléphone et je
voudrais vous dire bravo pour tout ce
que vous faites pour l'association
parce que franchement je sais que c'est
le combat de toute votre vie et vous
êtes exceptionnel j'ai des écoutes
partout de tout le travail que vous
faites je dois déjà vous dire bravo
merci vous dites moi la vérité ce soir
il ya un biopic sur votre fils vous
l'avez vu est ce que vous êtes content
de ce biopic est ce que vous avez pleuré
quand vous l'avez vue forcément
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est réussi
est ce que vous étiez vraiment pour ce
projet oui je vous écoute l'appui un
moment là je ne m'attendais pas à ce que
ce genre de débat mais je vais faire
court parce que vous parlez de tf1 au
parisien
moi je vais vous dire une chose tf1 tf1
a rendu mon fils heureux exactement c
est tf1 toujours été là pour
l'association
on a fait des émissions en direct on a
fait les séries times ça nous a ramené
des millions d'euros l'association et à
partir du moment où je vous la famille
donc laurent se dire qu'il y ai moi même
on a donné notre accord pour ce pays je
vois pas la place que l'on peut laisser
à la polémique
exact cipollini qu'il doit y avoir ce
vis-à-vis de la famille lemarchal donc
la vie oui mais tessin je vois pas ce
qu'ils ont à voir là dedans puisque si
on n'avait pas donné notre accord tf1
n'aurait jamais fait ce biopic
c'est depuis qu'on l'a voulu on l'a
voulu pour le combat commun contre la
mucoviscidose couler des messages par
est ce qu'ils vont voir le biopic ce
soir on verra les retours de main mais
ccdh fort pour le combat contre la
mucoviscidose un gamin qui vit avec
avait dit alors j'écoutais jean-pascal
tout à l'heure il ya pas qu est la vie
comme ici doses puis c'est aussi un
message universel pour tous les gens qui
vivent là
ce que nous ou qui ont vécu les mêmes
sociaux nous nous on a choisi à force
d'inventer on a on a choisi de se battre
et c'est un peu le message universel
qu'on voulait faire passer à travers la
vie de grégory qui a été qui a été
connue et ses salles et des sages vous
laisse apprécier fait qu'ils respectent
et de a à z avec les producteurs le
scénariste de réalisation on était avec
le hong lei parce que qui a eu l'idée de
faire ce biopic pierre sébastien charbit
hercules s'est inquiété de la star
academy à l'époque mathieu que
j'embrasse dont il est coproducteur
mathieu est un mec c'est cette personne
qui a toujours été avec nous alors oui
c'était fin vis et des gènes qui est née
voilà qui est qui et qui profitent de ce
genre de chose peut-être ce cas ci
profite mémoire qui est en jeu je ne
peux que le retirer bonjour cadre avant
parce que ça nous a beaucoup aidés je
vous garantis que tout ce qu'on a
récupéré grâce à tf1
ça nous a permis de construire la maison
bien sûr à ouvrir dix depuis 2000 21
savent nous permet de nous occuper
correctement du la qualité de
l'innovation on ne fait que du bien quoi
par rapport à tout ça mais encore une
fois c'est nous qui avons donné notre
accord donc franchement je sais que
j'entends là depuis duster non mais
c'est tombé quoi j'aurais d'hervé nous
aurons henry pire que ce je vous dise
pierre vous avez vous allez mine de rien
mis un terme aux polémiques parce que
comme vous dites
et moi je vous dis au moyen d'un truc
qui me rend fou c'est que quand on fait
rien on nous tombe dessus quand on fait
quelque chose on nous tombe dessus on
n'aurait rien fait sur une à gorée
lemarchal
tout le monde aurait dit bah vous avez
vu tf1 ne fait rien sur grégory
lemarchal ils font quelque chose pour
leur dis ah bah oui mais c'est parce que
c'est pour faire de l'argent dans ces
cas là on fait rien nous il nous arriver
la même chose à chaque fois qu'on fait
quelque chose on donne une maison oui
mais pourquoi ils ont donné deux maisons
mais c'est parce qu'ils ont un
partenariat avec quelqu'un oui mais
moins pressants
il est de toute façon tf1 c'est comme
toutes les autres chaînes qui sont là
pour faire de leur examen et ont fait de
l'argent avec le messie en faire
profiter l'association comme ils le font
et basse exceptionnelle de l'argent la
star ac 1
les autres stars a bien sûr voilà donc
je pense pas que moi je vois pas ça
comme ça je vois sujet c'est la corde
qui va aider les gens quand ils vont
regarder le pic de serre
en tous les cas c'est de la mission
qu'on s'est donné des airs toujours bien
parler de nous en fait
là c'est clair vous parlez de grégory
parce que ça touche beaucoup et puis je
vais faire un bisou particulier à sofia
blé et à francescas et les amants j'ai
eu la chance de rencontrer grégory vous
étiez venus voir la radio à l'époque à
rire et chansons d'un garçon afrique
mais que déconner on avait rigolé
ensemble on s'était mal passé un moment
exceptionnel c'est un moment qui restera
gravé dans ma mémoire et serait de
remercier aussi pierre vous avez vu le
biopic est ce que ça a été dur pour vous
de le regarder
oui c'est évident on a un oeil objectif
d'ailleurs dès le départ mais d'abord
comme souci on l'a vendu
donc on a aidé aussi pour le montage à
aider on a corrigé certaines choses et
au final effectivement pour rien vous
cacher on avait cédé 10 min on était
dans une pièce avec les violences et les
dix minutes qui ont suivi la fin du
biopic de la destine aux entrées 10 youn
et on s'est pas dit un mot
donc on essayait de comprendre les
larmes coulaient évidemment et à parce
nous ça nous en rappelle d'autres choses
aussi donc c'est un peu logique mais je
pense que c'est une belle réalisation
et encore une fois il va qui s'adresse à
travers la vie de règles a pas tous les
autres à tous les gens qui souffrent
merci pierre et bravo pour tout ce que
vous faites encore et j'espère vraiment
qu'un jour on pourra se rencontrer tous
les deux encore une fois ça me fait
extrêmement plaisir merci parlement